hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in their
mechanics but 9 Aristotle approach is
something that he started discussing in
nikka mechanics book II in terms of
friendship mainly on should the
friendship continue when the friends
change and we don't mean changing just a
little bit but changing in ways that are
significant that put a strain on the
friendship that perhaps introduced
tensions or conflicts into the
friendship and for AG Aristotle he
doesn't seem to consider cases where you
know it's a familial relationship
they're kind of stuck with with family
and people change over time and that's
not something he worries particularly
about you can say it's possible for a
son that's something to be disowned by
his father but not vice versa but he
doesn't follow that up well we're more
interested in our cases in terms of
these three fundamental goods than
Aristotle has has used to distinguish
types of friendship and he says this
actually happens quite often in terms of
certain kinds of friendships you know
the basis for the relationship changes
particularly when it's a matter of
usefulness told some tamarin or a total
crazy moment or pleasure
hey don't a total hey news those sorts
of things are by their nature rather
shifting you know he gives the example
of younger people this is coming up in
book eight where he says that they're
really driven primarily by pleasure so
they have a lot of friendships based on
pleasure you know you see kids on the
playground playing with each other and
saying hey meet my new friend right and
there are their friends because they
enjoy that activity together but they
can quickly break up as well and then
cease being friends because the
pleasures not only are fairly fleeting
but as children grow they they begin to
appreciate different pleasures and to
leave you know more childish pleasures
behind my skin be an example for my own
children a frequent commentator certain
television shows that we used to watch
together by is the adult having to watch
the show but getting something out of it
and I'm the kid you know being very very
happy with the show you know later on
and say hey you want to watch this you
want to watch that and both of my kids
would say that's for babies I don't
watch that skirt at the fitting anymore
you know
Aikido boys a lot of humble but now I
hate you know or you know pick whatever
you want that's pretty common and as
people age their pleasures change and so
you know Aristotle thinks that it's
perfectly reasonable if you're in a
relationship that is fundamentally based
on sharing pleasures together if you no
longer get that pleasure out of it why
should you continue their relationship
your soul it doesn't see there being
sort of a sense of duty to just you know
maintain contact stay in touch you know
see the person socially so that you can
remember the friendship he doesn't say
that you couldn't do that but he thinks
that it's quite reasonable for us to
bring up relationships that no longer
serve us in that way we were we weren't
friends with the person on the basis of
who they are at their core identity
we're friends with them on the basis of
the pleasure
they provided them with us same thing
with with the usefulness so that he says
it makes perfect sense there is a
problem that he talks about then this is
really worth thinking about like I quit
here this is a frequent issue this is a
frequent subject there you go
a man may well complain if though we
really liked him for the profit or
pleasure he afforded we had pretended to
love him for his character this happens
a lot people tell each other that they
are friends with each other
on the basis of their character who they
are that they're going to be friends
forever friends no matter what happens
yeah really what they're doing is
they're just trying to get something out
of it I'll give you a sort of an example
that I saw when I was in college
something that I found quite painful to
watch year after year after year there
were these you know older guys generally
juniors and seniors quite often within
you know some sort of Club or fraternity
and they were just waiting for the new
crop of freshman students to come in
fresh out of high school you know fairly
naive lots of young girls through them
these guys would immediately connect up
with and start sweet-talking and tell
them how interested they were in them
and how they found them so beautiful so
fascinating all these sort of
characteristics right you said well then
that's primarily a matter of pleasure
and they're gonna be exchanging pleasure
once they you know what once they're
involved romantically but really what
was going on is is these guys we're
telling these girls how how great they
were as persons and these girls were you
know quite happy to hear that you know
coming in as as freshmen suddenly
there's somebody and you know somebody
who matters on campuses is paying
attention to and you could tell that you
know
the way that these guys try they have no
regard for these girls at all and it's
shortly after sleeping with them they
like give them the cold shoulder and
that would be the end of it and it looks
a lot for the nation's some of the guys
had contests about this sort of thing
with each other I always found that that
sort of thing disgusting and trying to
warn girls about that but quickly gave
up because it was just a dynamic that
would keep on happening well that's an
example of somebody deliberately
misleading another person about the
basis for the friendship and then
breaking it off of the friendship
Aristotle says that it's possible for us
to be misled it's also possible for us
to mistake things to mislead ourselves
so he says here we go
and as with some of the oats at
differences between friends most
frequently arrive when the nature that
friendship is not what they think it is
when a man has made a mistake and it's
fancy that he was loved for his
character without their having been
anything in the friends behavior to
warrant that assumption
he has only himself to blame so if the
person didn't lead us on if they didn't
you know tell us things that really were
stretching the truth or just weren't
true at all then it's our fault if we
get that one and we shouldn't be so
naive as to think that people who are
just business contacts really love us
for who we are I mean they may use that
vocabulary in the business context you
know in sales or in networking events
but we should know about it we should be
smarter than that there are some things
we should be naive
similarly with romantic relationships
it's it's tough especially when we're
young but we should probably be a little
bit more guarded and not give give you
know get into our hormones and hosts
right so if we're misled by their form
is mistaken that's our own fault what if
somebody else misleads us Aristotle says
this is a very bad thing he says when
he's been deceived by his friends
pretense there is ground for complaint
against the deceiver and that's fairly
neutral in fact this person is a worse
newer than those who counterfeit the
coinage that was a bad thing in ancient
times that would get you killed
right counterfeiting quench insofar as
his offense touches something much more
precious than money
so if counterfeiting the coinage is bad
or for example in academic contexts if
plagiarism is a despicable action then
you know in essence passes off somebody
else's work as one's own he's in effect
theft right deceiving somebody about the
basis for their friendship is even more
despicable it's it's you know
deliberately counterfeiting the coinage
friendship or or love and so every
simple thinks that you know we should we
should be quite condemning of that sort
of behavior
now another topic that he talks about in
this issue is well what should we do
about the good person who becomes bad
how should we treat a person who we are
connected with and our friends with
because they are in fact a genuinely
good person what happens when they slide
down the you know the the slippery slope
or you know maybe a very bumpy slope
lots of lots of the points along the way
and become a bit a bad person here so
says well this is tricky there's two
ways we could look at this what is that
it would be reasonable to cut them loose
and say I can't be friends with you
anymore because we don't really have
anything in common
we're no longer on the same page morally
speaking and as a matter of fact because
you're a bad person
I shouldn't be friends with you I should
not be loving what is baby this is an
Aristotelian take on things so it would
be reasonable to break off the the
friendship in that case he does also
suggest another possibility though and
this is quite interesting he says maybe
we actually get a duty to try to help
that friend he says perhaps we should
not break it off yeah everything
but only when our friends have become
impurity bad so long as there is some
possibility of our friend making their
way back to goodness
perhaps with us as as some sort of
contributory clause or a support system
or providing resources something like
that we should in fact help them he
makes a really great argument here he
says so long as they're capable of
reform or even more about to help them
morally than we would be to assist them
financially why because character is a
more valuable thing than wealth it has
more to do with friendship so if we
really value to that person for who they
are and now they start to become a bad
person but they could be steered back
towards goodness Aristotle says look
you'd help out a friend in bad financial
circumstances and that's extrinsic goods
you're talking now about who that person
is in themselves so you think about for
example friends who are going through
difficult times the things that often
take a toll upon us like you know
divorces for example or or deaths or
losses of position and jobs these are
things that for people who are not
completely virtuous that includes myself
by the way speaking from experience here
those can really throw a person for a
loop a person might say well screw it
being a good person doesn't help me at
all it's a kind of common reaction and
you know what do we do in the friend
like that
so long as we think that they have some
possibility some real possibility not
not just some abstract imaginary
possibility of coming back into the fold
we should try to extend a hand to them
and help them out because character is
more valuable than money the last thing
that Aristotle talks about this last
discussion he has to do with well what
about when we have the opposite happen
the friend doesn't go from being good to
be bad but the friend goes from being
maybe you know sort of good to being
super
good or the friend goes from just being
a run-of-the-mill cat person to being
somebody who's a major player there's
some sort of drastic change in
superiority he says are we then to
behave towards a former friend he says
suppose one friend to have remained the
same while the other has improved and
become greatly the superior of virtue
since you're the latter keep up the
friendship and the Aristotle says it's
tough to say the wider the gap the less
there is a basis for friendship there
both the friendship of the original sort
so he says that this is really clear
like when two people who are friends in
childhood one may have remained a boy in
mind while the other is a man of the
highest ability
how can they be friends when they have
different tastes and different likes and
dislikes they will no longer even injure
each other Society but without this we
can't really have a friendship so when
you know you start out you know in your
small town and you've got your circle of
friends that you you know do these fun
activities with after after school
during high school and now you go off to
college and they stay behind and some
you know some of them actually engage in
intellectual life on their own say
through YouTube right and the other is
just you know hang around and drink and
watch TV right after a while you come
back and you're like I don't really have
that much in common with these people
anymore I really liked them but now you
know it's kind of awkward when we get
together at the bar you know over
Thanksgiving right you've lost that
basis for the friendship that the same
thing can happen to us as well if we
just sit still and other people develop
so he says are how should we behave them
towards these people he says are we
behave towards a former friend in
exactly the same way as if you've never
better a friend perhaps we ought to
remember our past intimacy and just as
we think it right to show more kindness
strangers maybe we should pay some
attention to the person but they're
they're no longer friends
in that case and so there's a lot of
times when a change in the person's
changing the kind of persons that we're
talking about can actually produce a
breakdown or you know an irrevocable
break to the friendship